[Musique]
annoncez vous terminez non non je
commence si vous disiez gentiment
bonjour bonsoir bonsoir
surtout qu'au fond c'est pas vus depuis
trois semaines c'est bien l'avouer assez
vrai les deux dernières émissions est
enregistrée alors ma foi on s'est
souhaité la bonne année
trois semaines avant j'espère que ça ne
soit pas mal au contraire alors
avez-vous c'est ce soir musique pour
vous mais le monde joue un petit air de
mandali oui ça s'appelle une mandoline
effectivement à découper les pommes de
terre à l'aide de sept mandats les nous
annoncer des rognons mais coupe du
pommeau de terrain
les quatre compères pastor ce soir non
de l'huile elles vont être à quoi la
garniture ses pommes de terre oui ça va
être la garniture et rognant alors je
commence par la fin toujours très
logique d un jour un peu d'huile et de
beurre dans une poêle
voilà une toile e shop les pommes de
terre ont été coupés en lamelles
naturellement commandes dans le même
sens d'une obligation alors en selle un
tout petit peu et poires salez poivrez
et mélangez un petit peu et puis voilà
qui pourrait en bleu est prêt à porter
nous allons y passer très rapidement du
problème alors voyez vous je les
laisserais sur les un tout petit peu
puis je vais les passer à cuire dans une
cocotte fermé où elles vont cuire tout
doucement sans nom que nous font le
restant de l'émission simplement de
roissy la cocotte n'est pas dans
laquelle dieu mettre un petit peu de
beurre aillé lourd voilà et plus je m'en
vais les choses déjà assez chaude
maintenu car de feuilles si vrai
lauriers car de fruits ou de faire
tomber quelques feuilles de thym laurier
c'est par bien les prendre les unes avec
les autres et sortait un petit peu sache
que tout prenne bien de leur beurre et
l'huile
et puis non stop
voilà je verse les pommes de terre là
dedans vous voulez un petit couvercle
le petit couvercle et nous allons mettre
à cuire tout doucement sur les oignons
je voulais un nommément l'espace en
revient aussi aux rognons de veau pas
alors voyez où je m'en vais enlever la
graisse mais pas entièrement pas toute
la grèce selon les syndicats il achètera
chez vous vous demandez à ce qu'ils
enlèvent ne soit pas complètement cidre
la grèce mais pas tous s'il ne paye pas
surtout absolument qu'ils n'arrivent pas
la petite poussine non non non non
seulement la petite ou mais il est comme
je vais faire maintenant un petit peu de
graisse dessus dites moi c'est
indispensable que ce soit des rognons de
veau on parle toujours de rognons beau
mariage suppose que les rognons de veau
sont évidemment les meilleurs oignons
c'est plus sain plus fait bon détruits
ou ici je vais m en tout petit peu
d'huile que vous avez me donner on peut
le faire avec les autres quand même je
reviens bien que ce soit moins bon là la
même recette oui au où il n'y a pas
d'exclusive non mauvaise pas recommandé
il ya d'autres méthodes pour faire
d'autres réunions qu'allez vous faire de
cette graisse qui demeure là pour le
moment je n'en sais rien mais si j'avais
à l'utiliser cette graisse on peut la
faire fondre et s'en servir un petit peu
comment se sert du saindoux ce qu'une
guest excellent absolument d'excellents
un tout petit peu de beurre à 6 c'est au
contraire une journée meilleur grèce qui
existent c'était un préjugé que j'avais
alors voilà eh bien nous allons si vous
voulez pendant que ce rognon si allah
vous mettez entier je vais me entier
arrivent sur l'airé puis le second je
vais alors le pl est complètement parce
que oui 2 pour la même recette mais pas
tout à fait la même recette en réalité
c'est à dire je vous fais à voir comment
on peut réaliser soit d'une façon soit
d'une autre une recette à peu près
identique c'est-à-dire que le résultat
sera très semblable serait proche très
proche l'un d'eux
et néanmoins des méthodes de cuisson
absolument les mêmes éléments et même
des mêmes facilités pour l'instant celui
la rissole tranquillement wii u turn 30
couleurs et oui complètement suis là
vous allez voir il sera entièrement
dégraisser attendez je ceci voilà alors
maintenant vous pouvez maillot
alors ici ça y est ça a pris couleurs et
bien immédiatement je vais aller mettre
ce rognon au four en cours très chaud
avec la casserole vous serez gentil si
j'ai oublié de me rappeler qu'il est fou
mais nous allons bon et bien voilà la
première partie de notre mission
la première recette et en haute alors
maintenant nous allons faire
selon une autre méthode qui consiste à
le faire directement alors là je mets
une casserole au chaud et je m'en vais
et mince et pour le moment je la loupe
leurs oignons en deux et je m'en vais
enlever au milieu mais vous n'avez pas
enlever la wii mais je vais le faire
alors voyez vous ici j'enlève cette
partie grâce et nerveuse au milieu il
comporte en même temps les canaux du
rhin de données rognon ça et la petite
enveloppe qui te connaissent pas qui
s'enlève alors tout seul voyez vous ça
va super bien peu à leurs 10 ans avait
facilement devant déjà dès le départ
différent oui mais ça va déchanter au
four et la 800 est un peu différente et
nous jetterons la grèce enfin nous nous
éliminons si vous préférez la grèce
depuis son ce qui reviendra à peu près
au même
oui mais ça aura des chuté également
c'est ce que je vous disais bon alors
ici ne pas nous allons l'esc a loupé sa
voix nyon c'est à dire de couper en
petits morceaux comme ceci ça fait
beaucoup de bruit pour rien
j'ai beaucoup d'autres choses qu'il faut
et quand je dis des choses
bon alors ça nous coupons aux petits
voiliers ou en morceaux moyens pas trop
petit c'est important que ce ne soit pas
trop petit et c'est important que ce
soit assez régulier je le salue
également jeu le pouvoir aussi et vous
allez c'est très gentil de me passer un
tout petit peu d'huile que vous
n'oubliez pas vous dire non non je pense
qu'on en dise médian t il de me le
rappeler
il reste que ce n'est pas des rognons la
moutarde le crois oui je crois
alors voyons il faut que ce soit très
chaud il est au départ très chaud les
gens tenant le coup oui je vais le
regarder
[Musique]
elle retournait bien comme ça alors je
reviens ici
il jette les rognons saler poivrer dans
la sauteuse et loyers vont immédiatement
gérer parties viennent façon à ce qu'il
soit saisie assez vite c'est toulouse
n'est pas interdit
non non non pas du tout d'ailleurs le
laurier le thym est une fois pour toutes
dans les pommes de terre que nous
retrouverons tout à l'air et par
conséquent dans les deux sens voyez-vous
là on va les retourner à l'aide d'une
fourchette à deux dents mais sans les
piquiers très importants sont les
fichiers simplement bon et bien voilà
voulez vous me passez des champignons
qui sont là-bas catherine il s'agit de
rognons qui va pour environ 2 personnes
si on veut entre une et deux personnes
selon la gourmandise de 1 mètre 4
champignons et don généreux j'ai bien
senti mais ça va très bien j'ai minci
des champions mais gros c'est à dire clé
les tranches de champignons un peu et
fait un peu plus parce que j'ai
l'habitude de le payer au lit pendant la
cuisson du certaines personnes entrent
en jeu dans sa phase le caoutchouc
oui parce que ça peut faire quelque
chose si on n'a pas la précaution de
saisir leurs oignons et si surtout on le
laisse pour longtemps que lui alors il
faut le saisir le coloré qui ça y est
c'est terminé on les gouttes comme on
peut le voir
ça y est ça suffit alors maintenant les
champignons si vous voulez bien
vont suivre le même processus que leurs
oignons
ils ont d'ailleurs bénéficié du même oui
de la même ville et peur de cuisson
statue en bois
[Musique]
merci café mais c'est gourmand et les
champignons en magasin et oui voyez
c'est pour moi ça me dit ça vous ces
gourmands se dit chez nous oui mais là
quand quelque chose est gourmand ses
commandes y aussi ces jaloux aussi cinq
lignes en sont jaloux ça veut dire que
cette île sont délicats à préparer ça
risque de c'est une sauce plus tôt qui
risque d'être jalouse dans mon jargon
vous parlez comme édition dictionnaire
ces derniers devaient donc s'est remis
un petit peu d'heures et je vais
légèrement assaisonnées ça laisse
indifférent comme c'était un tout petit
peu non je n'ai pas de support
aujourd'hui voilà confusion eh bien nous
allons les juger terminé ça y est on va
avoir l'occasion de les refaire les
faire fuir un tout petit peu alors pour
le moment nous devons les arrêter
ce n'est pas grave je voudrais une
assiette alors je vais les écouter comme
ceux ci pas pour le moment d'aller voir
allons y arriver à les mélanger daisy
chaleur des échalotes directement dans
la casserole voyez-vous une cuillerée à
soupe une forte puis arrêt à soupe
d'échalotes et un petit peu de beurre
aussi servi de ce pacte il vous dit
qu'il ya une cuillère à soupe c'est vrai
voyez là je trouve si chambert
aujourd'hui aussi j'en mettais trouve
pas cesser si seulement si je mettais
trop de beurre à catherine serait un
très grave inconvénient c'est que tout à
l'heure ne pourrait pas arriver à lier
il va briller ça fait partie le le burke
lorsqu'il y en a trop fait tourner une
fois et c'est extrêmement ennuyeux n'y a
rien fait et où alors maintenant je
rajoute à nouveau car les champignons
ça s'est terminé merci et puis si vous
voulez les chauffer ici vous allez où
les rognons en rendu de la cuisson pas
mais c'est très bon tu n'avais pas la
perdre
voilà maintenant six dedans mais vous
conservez toujours précieusement nous
venions juste après je vais les plans b
si vous voulez bien me donner le cognac
et une allumette
excusez moi si vous permettez moi je
mets moi vous allez vous éloigner un
petit peu tout le monde est en place
très bien bravo vers mentalité je ne
veux pas prendre
là alors je flambe légèrement cognac et
voulait laisser flamber pendant ce temps
là je le laisse plan des puis je reviens
et comme ceci parce que là ce peut être
très très tôt et celui ci est très très
vite au contraire la chanteuse je vais
garder ici comme ceci simplement au
chaud pendant que je vais préparer la
liaison donc il va servir à nous
poursuit donc parler de ça en ce moment
mais je vais regarder en fait à deux la
voilà et bien maintenant je vais
préparer la moutarde car c'est tout de
même important le moteur alors voici de
la moutarde de bordeaux d'un moteur de
l'estragon boutade
alors là beaucoup parce que c'est la
véritable confiture cette histoire là ça
naît ça n'a de moutarde que le nom
motards de là alors ici de la vision
l'incision alors voyou je vais la mettre
dessus comme ça pour que vous puissiez
voir la dijon il y en a à peu près la
moitié de ce que j'ai mis un lien une
cuillère à café carrément de bordeaux
laisse pas de moutarde estragon qui ne
sent rien que l'extra gonds bien entendu
et puis en plus alors de la motor de
dijon si elle est très forte et de la
moutarde également de champagne qui est
également assez forte voyez-vous à une
couleur entre les différents 2 bordeaux
de dijon et de champagne c'est ça tout
les croirait mans alors dire que la
publicité est interdite à la télé
on a pris toutes les marques ah oui la
crème je vous prie catherine c'est trois
sortes de moutarde sont indispensables
défaut ou là ou là comme un autre moment
on pourrait la faire avec une seul
moteur ça s'appellerait plus aux trois
moteurs oui vous voyez où je te mets
langue comme ceci avec de la crème
encore un peu plus de crème si vous
voulez bien voilà et bien maintenant je
m'en vais glissez cette crème moutarde
et dans les champignons l'échalote et le
fond de cuisson est pour l'instant
toujours pas les rognons toujours toile
et renault la voyez un medic danser à
besoin sympathique et bien c'est fini il
faut pas faut pas aller plus loin ou
vers sont les rognons maintenant dedans
comme ceux ci la rentrée nous allons
laisser ce plat mijoté entend améliorer
c'est une façon de parler il faut pas
que ça bouge surtout maintenant non nous
allons les laisser au chaud et nous
allons nous occuper de la seconde de
recettes alors celle là elle est finie
cela est terminé vous donc ni crème et
les trois moutarde voile c'est la
liaison sel poivre dans les chapitres en
échange nous laissons le bon
je reviens chez christie's alors là il
faut se méfier sa façon les directions
surtout à aucun moment vous tous je
voudrais ce récipient qu'elle apporte
éléphants ce début d'année
voilà merci une assiette
voilà merci et café alors là où je me
débarrasse ça c'est pas de la grèce
en tout cas pas pour ça c'est
récupérable pour autre chose mais là est
la question le vin blanc que voilà les
gars ont des glaces et je vais laisser
réduire
c'est exactement fond de la casserole ou
à cuire l'oignon
c'est ça non mais ça va bien avant au
nord alors nous reviendrons à la
moutarde de bordeaux tout à l'heure
alors se renie au chaud pour le moment
une seconde nous allons regarder aux
sources parce que c'est à dire je
voudrais ici réaliser le fond de sauce
qui va nous servir à faire s'il veut
rien au talent mais là je vais reprendre
la moto comme j'ai fait tout à l'heure
devant metz ainsi généraux lieu de la
mélanger avec de la crème je vais la
mettre directement
oui oui ce n'est absolument plus besoin
voilà ça c'est terminé on n'en parle
plus moutarde 2 à motta de bordeaux
celle ci dans le vin blanc et ceux de la
champagne pourtant pas que des gens
courageux mais elles ne sont pas des
aromates
non c'est la moutarde normale d'un fort
de la bouteille comment parce que même
dans la moutarde de dijon il ya de la
force de la voir maintenant non mais je
non je moi pour moi voilà une seule et
unique quand il faut comme l'église
romaine enfin c'est pas moi c'est me
semble comme ça voilà alors que les
séduire voyez vous cette moutarde en
présence du fonds de déglaçage que
j'avais fait tout à l'heure et
maintenant immédiatement je vais
m'occuper d'eux descat loupé ce rognon
voyez vous je la saignée mais c'est très
bien car alors il faut que ce soit
chemin
oui mais dans une colère qui non
seulement est un voyou je le coupe ici
en rondelles comme ceux-ci film mesrine
mais sans exagération ne fait pas alors
il est rose et c'est très important
enfin il ne doit pas être tout à fait
cuit il doit être presque cuit donc
c'est la véritable cuisson là il serait
venu tourner on est riche et l'autriche
ont d'ailleurs jamais nous savons pas
mais ça le dos à preuve la voilà eh bien
ceux ci voiliers qui a bien et précis
alors bordeaux
moi je trouve que ce sont vraiment de
recette bien différente
vous appelez bien différente oui
effectivement il ya du rognon de riz 2
mais à part ça oui à la motta dans les
deux il y à du vin blanc et vous verrez
qu'il y aura du cognac à la fin de celle
ci aussi
alors ici je vais ajouter maintenant
pendant que ce viol et d'eau chaude dû
rajouter du beurre par petites parcelles
comme ceux-ci lier la sauce
hors du feu vous pouvez remarquer que je
suis déjà fort du tour soutenir un petit
peu comme ça s'il vous plaît et je vais
pouvoir alors j'ajoute encore du vert
allez vous comme elle devient onctueuse
alors voulez vous me donnez le cognac je
vous prie mais avec plaisir le cognant
tient jusqu'à 20h le chiffre abstrait
comme le font nos curiosités d'art
petit-mars alors ici je vais ajouter une
cuillère à soupe environs de cognac est
lui encore mettre un tout petit peu de
peur très peur
finie analyse et je vais assaisonner je
vais assaisonner avec un petit peu de
sel et un petit peu de cayenne celui-là
au fisc l'autre nous la voix s'est
incliné 4-3 eh bien il ya eu deux
départs ce départ à des départs
l'assaisonnement de lancel etc
alors ici je vais ajouter un petit peu
de poivre de cayenne noyau là et puis du
sel normalement très peu aussi puisque
nous avons déjà une partie sa porte
eh bien je vais mettre au chaud en herbe
tendre l attention que ça ne vaut pas et
je m'en vais verser les rognons dedans
mais alors là il va falloir qu'ils aient
un supplément de cuisson il faut les
faire chauffer tout ensemble sans faire
bouillir
mais ça c'est facile vous allez voir
nous donne rien
high res trop souple jeunes une rose non
ils ne seront plus rose parce que ce
qu'ils vont finir d'une part et d'autre
là ils vont au circuit rendu qui peut
soit un tout petit peu bon eh bien je
crois que je vais mettre ceux-ci
contiennent espère maintenant je peux
arrêter ici complètement laissé ici
officiel ses rognons si ceux-ci
également au chaud voilà puis intime
c'est je vais m'occuper de ces pommes de
terre une idée peut-être ce qui vous
fait dire ça c'est que là il ya des
champignons aussi les noms les voilà
bien si vous voulez le voulons
maintenant préparer le plat et un fume
et je voudrais le pl oui mais je
voudrais tourner la planche de coca à
tourner la caméra de l'autre côté on
s'est vraiment fait ça non voilà alors
ici nous allons de terre sont bien
surtout maintenant comment faire
attention parce qu'elle se casse mhz
alors nous allons les écouter en partie
juste puis ta points donc il a fallu 20
minutes de 10 heures à peine et vous les
aviez pourtant parce que c'est tellement
ne peut pas non plus les coûts mais
aussi ses travers et vous laissez bien
au fond le
oui pas seulement emporté
oui du bourget départ du beurre de
l'huile les pommes de terre coupées à la
mandoline ou pas tintin bon alors ici
voyez vous ça a chauffé et l'homme fait
attention les queues de casseroles sont
très très chaud alors maintenant nous
sommes assurés d'une bonne chaleur
régulière voyez-vous pour sa bouille
holmes qui peut aussi voyez vous il faut
faire très attention ne pas aller laisse
aller trop loin en ébullition nous
allons tout de suite les passes et ceci
au chaud aussi allons prendre des
cocottes comme ceux ci en bim et à nous
allons verser une cuillère le savez bien
la chaleur surtout c'est ça oui ou alors
attention à la chaleur n'ont laissé là
au chaud je vous prie catherine si vous
avez souci de vous inviter je vous avais
invité chrétiens non c'est bien sûr il
ya invité tous les cameramans
aujourd'hui la détruisons pas le temps
de goûter parce qu ils sont obligés de
passer les génériques mais
bon alors si vous voulez nous allons
c'est très social aura plus rien fait
autrement nous avons fini cette émission
trop tôt attendez je vais quand même
alors voyez c'est bien chaud c'est
presque trop la paire 6 sur les pommes
de terre assez largement
on peut aussi en mettre si vous voulez
sur un une des recettes pas sur les deux
buts alors voici les pommes de terre qui
vont avec voici leurs oignons aux trois
moutarde mais qui a été qui n'est pas
sans ambition sans champignons et sans
crème et un autre au trône auteur de qui
a aidé champignons et de la crème alors
à bien voilà alors si vous voulez que
nous répétions la recette catherine je
crois que nous en avons le temps dans le
premier cas nous avons escaloper les
rognons nous avons fait sauter puis dans
la même casserole dans lequel avait
sauté les les
les rognons on a fait sauter les
champignons et puis ensuite on a fait
sauter on a fait brandir des échalotes
on a remis le tout ensemble
après avoir fait flamber les rognons et
puis nous avons lié avec de la crème de
lait et de la moutarde mélanger toujours
les trois motards en mettant beaucoup
plus de moteur de bordeaux que d autres
parce que elle est en réalité assez
douces bon deuxième rendez-vous qu'on a
mais si sa cote est à cause de de la
l'estragon alors deuxième cas nous avons
fait cuire leurs oignons entier à
l'accord que ça s'appelle fracture à la
coke c'est à dire en lui laissant au
tour un peu de cette gang qui est sa
graisse nous l'avons laisser dépouiller
tranquillement après l'avoir salez et
poivrez
et puis nous avons fait
comment dire est d'abord sorti leurs
oignons de sa de saghez depuis sous quel
nom l'a ressorti sa grille de cuisson
nous avons déglacer au vin blanc réduit
ce vin blanc pratiquement à glace
ajouter les moutards et ajouter du
beurre puis escaloper leurs oignons et
remis après l'avoir assaisonner avec du
poivre de cayenne et du sel alors voyez
vous les deux recettes sont très simples
vous avez vu que nous avons toutes les
deux pu les réaliser en moins de 20
minutes ainsi que les pommes sautées qui
les accompagnent alors qu à huy où le
royaume de cox se tint un aimable
féminisme ce oui c'est une histoire
d'abélard nom sort en réalité ce ne sont
pas les rognons c'est très bon c'est
très bon et en général ça se sait en
même temps que les crêtes
oui tant qu'à faire on garniture la
garniture à fameuse garniture financière
qui fait de petites quenelles de rognons
de cork de crête de coq bien aussi de
petites garniture de ce genre là dans
les phares source et de recettes car je
persiste à dire qu'il s'agit de recettes
bien qu'il y ait trois motard dans l'es2
de recettes très cousine germaine c'est
ça il est préférable de se servir des
rognons de veau
on peut le faire avec des rognons de
porc ou ou des rognons d'agneau d'y
aller ou pas de moutons corps que leur
union se prête à beaucoup de préparation
et l'excellente d'ailleurs maintenant
quel est l'intérêt de faire cette
recette avec trois motards au le mot 3
c'est joli ouais c'est bien mais tes
ancêtres pourrait bien coûter ses
recettes en l'air fort sympathique avait
alors à la semaine prochaine et bon
appétit car je pense que vous êtes
capable maintenant merci maman
en fait qu'un témoin soir
[Musique]